ready yeah one two three
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna be making a rainbow crepe
cake i made it once to test and it went
well so i feel like it's gonna be fine
what's the worst thing that's gonna
happen
[Music]
and right hand goes in right yeah okay
so right hand smooth motions
so i actually really love crepes they
were like my thing growing up same
that's right remember my first crepe you
do what happened um it was magical i had
it in canada i had nutella on it it was
also the first time i ever had nutella
so major moment yeah
um my
mom is dutch so i like didn't grow up
having american pancakes we had crepes
which i thought were amazing we i call
them dutch pancakes yeah but they're
crepes what's your like dream topping
well okay i do multiple in one sitting
so i have to have them all different
so one of them will be just plain sugar
and butter yeah of course she's like one
of my favorites maybe a little lemon for
sure another one will be peanut butter
peanut butter so good
sorry guys
okay so it's gonna take a little work
okay but i mean that was like number one
and it
can be the bottom crepe so
got a lot of tries to get this right so
no pressure
that looks like trash it looks like
trash it's a trash pancake
oh god
okay
just keep rolling okay we can eat this
one we can eat this one yeah
beautiful keep stay with it beautiful
oh i'm so confident i'm so good we got
the flip i think we pretty much got what
we needed i mean
amazing and we have what we need for the
kids we have what we need for the purple
so why don't we move on to
next color great
[Music]
yeah we have a long way to go well if
we're going to be eating a crepe cake i
might as well get my veggies in now
don't wait hold up yes wait we've got to
pause this
[Music]
you know i've never made crepes ever in
my life really yeah do you want to try
it you're just going to take it and
bring it to the center and then twirl it
around so it goes in like an even circle
okay and so when it starts to like look
like this
you do a little scrape scraper on the
edge a very professional term and then
you're gonna slowly lift it up pick it
up
gently
[Music]
okay okay
i guess okay make sure you swirl it fast
though okay middle put it down swirl it
okay and now you're gonna swirl it yeah
yeah yeah
there you go and like a gentle swirl
check just gently
[Music]
[Laughter]
now gently gently
you did it okay you've made a crepe
[Music]
it's our last color we've made it
through the rainbow i think it'll look
good yeah i better look good we can't do
this over
yay okay look how cool this is
now we're ready cool are you ready
let's do it
[Music]
okay ready yep
no no no no
yeah you do need to commit though that's
one thing you gotta do it's good for
life too ready yeah one two three
too much commitment
you committed a little too much we have
more cake one more cake ready wait
you're real
i don't know about that no no you don't
know i don't know either but we're going
to try it stay with it good job you can
keep going
just
stay right there
[Applause]
what technique do you think i should use
i think the go down one nice nice safe
slice
just pull it up
just
why are you not cooperating crapcake
what do you want from us who takes the
bite every time if you poke don't you
think you should be closer to the front
if you slice you should be closer to the
back so you think i should slice breathe
you can take your time
you have to clip it
perfect yes stop
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay go for it when you're ready peel it
nicely twist it perfect out yeah
why don't you take it off and do more
take leave it leave it out take it off
the fork
eat it
and then like do more okay
peel it again
do more keep eating it until
keep eating until the rainbow is gone
yes and then the final bite
is like stopping your face
final bite oh yes beautiful
oh i think it's a wrap it's a wrap wrap
on the rainbow okay we did it beautiful
i hope you all enjoy it
it's really delicious it's making it at
home
it won't take just this long just a
moment
okay
oh my god
[Music]
you